so this is a fun one this is from the
Eid wine Psalter 9th to 12th century and
that's Adam and Eve but the there is
speculation that the fruit that they're
eating there you see it is psilocybin
mushrooms because they're the only kind
of mushroom that grow like that so
that's pretty wild you might say and
then this is the I think it's called van
Asteria vine if I remember correctly and
it's what ayahuasca is made out of and
it has this double helix form which is
very very interesting and they the
people the natives nobody could figure
out how the hell they made this
ayahuasca which which transports people
spiritually in a very intense manner and
there's a whole religion based on it
like a modern religion as well as the
archaic religion and to make this stuff
they had to take two plants that don't
grow anywhere near each other and like
there's like a million plants in the
Amazon so like how do you figure that
out nobody knows and then you have to
cook them in this very particular way
for a particular amount of time before
you produce this stuff so one of the
plants has DMT in it which is a very
intense psychedelic but it's very short
acting and the other has an MAO
inhibitor so if you take the DMT and you
take the MAO inhibitor then the DMT trip
lasts for much longer and so that's what
these Amazonian natives figured out and
no one has any idea how they managed it
and if you ask them they tell you that
the plants told them how to do it which
isn't much of an explanation as far as
modern people are concerned but then
when modern people take the ayahuasca
and the plant so to speak starts to talk
to them they're a little less leery of
the whole theory that the plants had
something to do with this so you know
and these things that these I'm loathe
to talk about this because I'm not an
advocate for drug use but by the same
token you can't ignore empirical data
it's not reasonable and the empirical
data that psychedelic substances can
produce mystical experiences and that
those often have a transformative effect
I mean one of the latest studies showed
that if you took people who are dying of
cancer and you and you gave them
psilocybin in a sufficient dose to
produce a mystical experience that you
radically it decreased their their fear
of death it's like
you're going to think about that man
that's that's tough that's a tough
experiment you you just wouldn't expect
that that you think you take someone
you'd arranged them intensely and then
when they come back they're not even
though they're dying they're not nearly
as afraid of dying you know you got to
kind of wake up and smell the roses when
you see something like that and the
people who are doing this research are
very reliable people so there's the
Amanita muscaria you know there's this
old idea it's quite a funny idea
toadstools so flies like Amanita
muscaria and there's some this is
ridiculous there's some evidence that
they actually like getting stoned
so because animals will eat these like
reindeer will eat these things too and
they get pretty tripped out by them and
so I have this book on psychedelic use
among animals which is a small book but
and so so there's there's this idea that
toads used to sit around the they have
any NamUs carry and wait for the stone
flies to like buzz badly around them and
then snap them up so that's pretty funny
I think and so and you know there are
mushrooms in in the US that are the
oldest the oldest organisms on the
planet a there's one mushroom I can't
remember where it is but it covers
something like oh god I don't know like
square hundreds of square miles it's
like this huge thing because it's all
underground right and they have these
very complex networks of my Celia
they're called and they think the thing
is like a hundred and fifty thousand
years old something like that so there's
plenty of things about the world that we
don't know that's for sure